y volvemos para las noticias de la
economía vamos a actualizar con Juan
Pablo lucomín saludos para usted Juan
Pablo Buenos días Ángela segundo saludo
del día y vamos a empezar hablando de un
tema bien interesante Los Grandes de la
de la Inteligencia artificial se han
dado cuenta de los peligros que puede
traer esta tecnología una persona en
específico ha causado revuelo Ángela
nada más y nada menos que del pionero de
la Inteligencia artificial de Google en
el sector tecnológico ya se hablaba de
que el creador le está empezando a tener
temor a su propia creación tal y como
ocurre muchas veces en las películas de
ciencia ficción Hilton en una entrevista
con el New York Times dio las razones de
su renuncia a Google y la principal es
para poder advertir con libertad de los
riesgos de la Inteligencia artificial Él
pensaba por ejemplo que los aparatos
iban a ser más inteligentes que las
personas dentro de 30 o 50 años pero que
con el avance de la inteligencia ahora
está mucho más cerca en la entrevista
con el medio estadounidense se habla de
que la Inteligencia artificial de estos
días es como cuando llegó el navegador
web a finales de los años 90 y que
podría dar un gran avance a la sociedad
como la conocemos pero otros expertos
entre esos Simpson creen que podría
estarse tratando de pues liberar algo
peligroso a la naturaleza como se cita
en este diario Esto fue lo que el
publicó en sus redes sociales en el New
York Times de hoy Kate mets insinúa que
dejé Google para poder criticar a Google
en realidad me fui para poder hablar
sobre los peligros de la Inteligencia
artificial sin considerar como afecta
esto a Google Google ha actuado de forma
muy responsable
se conocieron Juan Pablo los datos de
inflación de la zona Euro a los 20
países que comparten el euro como moneda
no les fue nada bien no no al menos no
como esperaban la inflación se aceleró
levemente hasta el 7% interanual en
abril desde el 6,9% anual en marzo la
inflación subyacente que es la que
excluye los precios volátiles del
combustible y los alimentos Esta sí se
desaceleró y alcanzó en abril el 7,3%
interanual desde el 7,5% anual en marzo
Lo cierto es que la inflación se ha
desacelerado significativamente desde la
lectura de dos dígitos que registró el
año pasado pero los datos de este año
siguen siendo demasiado altos para los
objetivos del Banco Central europeo
quien Ahora tiene más argumentos para un
incremento de las tasas de interés que
se espera se conozca este jueves
hay avances Juan Pablo o bueno usted me
va a decir si no hay avances en el tema
del techo de la deuda de los Estados
Unidos son pequeños pasos son
desarrollos de esta noticia que venimos
desde hace pues meses incluso comentando
Y es que el presidente biden accedió por
fin a hablar de la propuesta aprobada
por los parlamentarios de la cámara de
representantes sobre el aumento del
límite de la deuda que pasó con la
condición de recorte de gasto biden
invitó a los cuatro líderes del Congreso
de La Casa Blanca para una reunión el
próximo 9 de mayo esta invitación llegó
justo después de que la secretaria del
tesoro Janet jelen informara a los
legisladores de lo preocupante que es la
situación si no se ponen de acuerdo con
el congreso y dio una fecha como
advertencia según ella el primero de
junio Estados Unidos podría cumplir
incumplir en un acuerdo y pues Por ende
caer en Pues un impago y esto Pues no ha
pasado nunca en Estados Unidos la cámara
de representantes aprobó la semana
pasada un paquete para Elevar el techo
de la deuda pero con amplios recortes de
que según han dicho los demócratas
impedirían el desarrollo de grandes
proyectos para los estadounidenses en su
momento varios legisladores dijeron que
el proyecto se hundiría cuando llegue al
senado de mayoría demócrata ya veremos
qué pasa si se ponen de acuerdo la
próxima semana y tenemos pendientes
algunos indicadores Así es con la
apertura de Wall Street porque pues esta
se dio en negativo debido a las
tensiones políticas del techo de la
deuda que acabamos de mencionar mientras
los inversores también esperan la
decisión de la política monetaria de la
reserva Federal las bolsas europeas
siguen operando en su mayoría la baja
luego de que se conocieran los datos de
inflación en Asia las bolsas cerraron
mixtas syd cerró con pérdidas luego de
conocerse que el banco de la reserva
Australia haya subido su tasa de interés
25 puntos básicos situándola hasta los
3,82% y por favor para el cierre
recordemos la cifra del día son los
2.250 millones de dólares que entregó el
Banco Mundial a bangladesh para el
desarrollo de cinco proyectos que
impulsarán la conectividad el el
comercio y la gestión del medio ambiente
en las últimas décadas el Banco Mundial
ha sido casi como un Aliado inversor de
bangladesh al que le ha concedido más de
40 mil 500 millones de dólares en
préstamos en el marco de por lo menos
370 proyectos programados Juan Pablo
pues gracias y que tenga buen día mañana
con mucha más información Claro que sí